oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] the fate of the Furious movie
clip woo prison riot scene yeah oh boy
yay John what we got a shout-out the
first person requested this is that are
they're always the ones who get the
shoutout
I love because I read all the comments
good and bad and I'm never sensitive to
the Rudraksha kaalia ooh
Raksha Kalia
there's not what they say danyetta
judgement nuts Kali ma it's Kali 70
maybe you're worried believe you beat me
this light a whole session to start let
me tell you something me and you one on
one no one else around I will beat your
rap like a Cherokee drum they did what
they will find out oh you better hope
that day never comes
oh [ __ ] oh I love this oh oh yeah
[Music]
malfunction malfunction oh yeah what
prison riot
[ __ ] yeah damn rubber bullets real book
I don't know okay oh [ __ ] [ __ ] cook
all right down as first I will beat your
ass like a Cherokee drum like a Cherokee
wrong I love it dude he's got his arms
up over that [ __ ] thing like that his
biceps the loner just like terrifying
terrifying terrifying John if I was if I
was Jason Statham right now I don't know
if I'd be talking so much [ __ ] I hope I
hope to 32nd I hope this clip of them
talking is at least 30 seconds longer oh
yeah it's gonna be like a whole five
minute you know yeah fourth different I
like them talking to save each other I
didn't do my braid for part actually
yeah oh these two were talking [ __ ]
right they can't do anything like I know
the action was going to be sweet and all
but like I just like there's something I
had Wayne Johnson and Jason Statham Jim
we're singing each other that is then
because his Hobbes and the fast and
furious is like the closest to wrestling
kind of character he has out there and
in the movie world it seems like him hey
girl Hobbes could be that's like karate
right there yeah
then and I like the way he fightin to
feel a little bit of fighting he does
here too it's like yeah that's a Jason
Statham martial artist guns and then you
know the rock would [ __ ] the way like
throw it around like a wrestler yeah
sort of
so yeah this now I don't want to see
this movie anymore that's all I needed
to see completely change my opinion
about going to stay at the Furious you
know I believe that this is what I came
to see thank you guys for saving me $26
I wonder what this prisons like pretty
easy to skate from no it's not yeah cuz
Jason Statham grab that one guy through
the slit and then shocked him in the
throat and then like thrust the cattle
prod up into some kind of sensor above
his door which then a walk a whole
prison a lot to the whole business Wow
that is it really not a high
maximum-security prison there yeah
therefore two of the most dangerous
people that's one of those movie things
where I'm like okay now I understand if
something were to go severely wrong I
guess it's a human rights thing too
where like I guess the doors ought to
open but really like if you just fried
the sensor of one door which is a whole
prison
open up for you and you know it's the
fast and furious movie so it's you know
kind of void but power makes the movies
brilliant is how usually excluding this
clip how how they really stick to
keeping it grounded and realistic and a
wine as much logic as possible
definitely so it is kind of shocking to
have seen such as I mean it's such a
convenient moment of you know maybe that
day will come and then and then this is
where opens right right away like that's
just not Fast and the Furious tough
there's issue a lot more build-up they
play out like a like a Tarantino film
yeah totally you know lots of lots of
heavy dialogue really intense characters
you know some cover songs like thrown in
you know what Oh Maj is two other movies
that well that's why the family theme
works because they is so much primarily
about its characters first and foremost
and then the action secondary you know
oh yeah totally I mean it's really I
really feel like they only star
focusing on the action the last couple
movies you know like maybe yeah so I'm
interested see if they'll add some more
action this one you know it looks like
they might have at least one fish slide
by the time its movies done they might
even walk this before they get out of
this prison I just got a hunch about I
don't know for sure though there's
nothing that I have no evidence to
support that well doesn't the trailer
ruin that they're like about to fight
and that Kurt Russell comes in with his
men and they all hold the guns up oh is
that what happened in the trailer like
and occur Russell's like that and that's
a clogger that I thought or something
okay yeah this is all simulation this is
all simulated all CGI this is a VR
mission okay this movie looks so much
fun today looks like a black D blast
full of circumcision alright well thanks
Kali ma per for requesting that we do
this done subscribe to the real rejects
hey John is the real rejects of social
media manager but first and foremost
he's the manager of Blum house studios
he cleans their whole third floor and I
do just the third one a festival look
that's a good floor that's for Jason
Blum resides just only him there's no
furniture he just hangs out again
hundred fifty storey building he's on
the third floor